Marting Millennials welcome to the
morning toast it is Good Friday and I'm
feeling good it's truly Good Friday
it's nice when the holidays you know
intersect like sometimes hanukkah's
falls on the same as Christmas so then
like the Jewish kids don't feel left out
when everyone else is getting presents
and you know it's nice it's like
everyone has Friday off whether well not
everyone but if you're Jewish or
Catholic yeah I don't know I kind of
like when they're spaced out cuz then
it's like more days off for everyone you
know because we would take Good Friday
off just to be respectful way cuz we're
good people cuz we're good and it's
Friday
I enjoy the goodness of a Friday just as
good as anyone else but unfortunately
Passover doesn't start until sundown so
that it's not an excuse for us not to do
a morning show but it is good that
Passover doesn't start till sundown
because that means we have about 12 more
hours to eat bread um so if you're
unfamiliar with the story of Passover
here's a little lesson many years ago
the Jews were exiled from Egypt Egypt
was always being ver just like first
thing slaved us and then they kicked us
out it's like we don't even want to be
here in the first place and on our way
out we're getting shoved out by the king
his name was Pharaoh and we're running
and we got escaped oh we weren't shoved
out because he came to get us and then
the sea swallowed him whole oh I thought
he just changed his mind no he was he
was coming after us we were escaping
okay so we're escaping because we
because we unleashed the ten plagues oh
my marrow and so we have slaves in India
to run like the wind
and God Elise to play 100 years five
hundred years two hundred five hundred I
swear know that I know and so God he led
us he gave the penny thing right before
hundred he gave the ten plagues to Egypt
and they were so distracted with their
boils that we had time to escape and
life that's out life started yeah and so
God we're all running and you know when
you're escaping there's not a lot of
time so we were making food for the road
obviously because we're Jewish and we
didn't have enough time for that food to
rise we were making bread and the bread
you know the yeast it's a whole thing
the bread Rises so we just took the
bread as it was which was like baking
for a minute and it came out these like
weird crackers so now in commemoration
of the hard times we faced as slaves who
were exiled from Egypt we now
commemorate by the eight days of
Passover not eating leavened bread so
matzah is basically the same ingredients
as where the crackers it's the same
ingredients as bread but it's bread that
a rose so it's more like a cracker and
it's actually pretty good with butter I
hate it's hard to cuz now if you think
about it like everything has like leaven
[ __ ] in it like pasta is wheat it's just
really annoying honestly it is it is
annoying and I take umbrage with like a
few some of the rules have passed over
just like a little too strict for me and
I personally believe if they had like
snacky O's back in the day like they
would have grabbed a bag of pretzels
ready because here you know people say
because you know I love fountain soda
and like so does a drink
people say they're syrup get a corn
syrup in this in like the liquid that
makes down soda has hum aids which is
like leavened is so great like to me I
don't follow that strictly I won't
outright eat a piece of bread just add
of respect for our ancestors yeah but I
totally understood our ancestors wanting
to get the [ __ ] out of the desert you
know yeah it's not for us and then God
opened up the red parted the Red Sea
we ran throw through and then it closed
behind them on the Egyptians ha ha ha ha
exciting stuff well there goes happen
was it being great for everyone I guess
I guess there are people of other
religions who might be feeling left out
it's nice to be like as a Jew I always
feel like excluded like from Christmas
so now it's like Passover is the same
day as Good Friday I'm like yeah I'm
with the Christians like I'm with that I
don't know I'm with the majority I love
holidays am I the only one well honestly
Passover is torturous because of the
bread thing and the Seder
but I'm so you know what it's like I
haven't been home in so long when I was
away I was like I'm so looking forward
to being bored at the Seder like that's
just the kind of like home vibes that I
need today I understand and we have dr.
Theodore for chairman leading our Seder
so it's shirt he's really hard to nail
down like he's was everyone one of him
for the savior but we're see obviously
family first and I think his experience
as a political refugee he can really
speak to the experiences of the Jews in
Egypt you know fleeing his country right
oh he knows what he can carry I'm sure
he's bred didn't live in either what's
really interesting is that a lot of the
people in the comments are saying and
I've heard this before that what they
learned about Passover just like Judaism
in general they actually learned from a
few episodes of the Rugrats like people
who aren't Jewish they had that episode
of emulating the whole Passover story
that's so cool I feel like can see stays
like don't have like Dora the Explorer
like goes to Egypt you know they have
that story that pig that's for the pig
yeah
talking a British accent right but like
there's no even like friends you learned
about the holiday armadillo you know
yeah we could we could be better at that
I feel like Glee was good for that to
learn a lot a lot of different people
that is so true Cleary actually
represented on Glee Glee was actually
like I think ahead of its time
it was it really I'm not sure it in a
new era yeah it didn't it was really
like an important show and I feel like I
learned so much about like music
obviously but more like different
cultures and just like the
understandings of people who are
different than me from Glee yeah I
[ __ ] love Glee and you know buddy
love more about Lea he's a big one of
Paltrow of it all you know I just I love
it everyone it's like one of those shows
where it's just cuz you are ugly doesn't
mean you're gonna go nowhere like but it
also does it on your own somewhere
really far but everyone's still around
yeah Michelle Becca Tobin you know Quinn
Fabray Darren Criss that's true yeah all
just psych around Naya Rivera yeah
that's true but then there are also
people like who were major characters
who truly went nowhere like what the
[ __ ] happened to mr. Shue and I'm not
mad about it
I've read the blinds oh my god shut up
what are they saying what do they say
about mr. Shue I'm not saying and he's a
teacher he seems so scary oh shut the
[ __ ] up and then like the mark ceiling
of it oh my god you know get so
multi-dimensional you know yeah Cory
Monteith also very tragic truly I had
some dark times on that show yeah but
also then we had like some amazing
Kristin Chenoweth moments you know great
show yeah jolly good show like and I do
the men's that will being Lea Michelle's
mom which it was like at something that
all of us just dreamed no no it's not
even that it's like idina menzel is not
Lea Michelle's mom they look exactly
like it's vile it was a perfect casting
truly well we have a lot of TV to talk
about because they caught up on every
tube I wasn't super moved by anything in
particular actually nothing and Real
Housewives of New York continues to
disappoint yep they get a ratings low a
five-year ratings of 1.1 million viewers
on Wednesday night's episode and I'm not
shocked no not at all
and so considering this is the worst
season in a while factually what do you
think they'll do to change it out of New
York well I think like them bringing in
Barbara was an attempt to shake things
up but like you can't bring in a
housewife who is just like a she's like
a sworn soldier of Lea
it's not interesting sell sword no
literally like she's not ever gonna like
shake things up in a real way because
she serves one Lord of Light and that's
Leanne
I mean LuAnn de Lesseps so they really
needed to bring someone in who either
has like a really like adversarial
relationship with someone or is
completely new and it's like weird like
Jennifer like was she didn't really
bring anything actually she brought a
lot but she was really interesting on
her own like in the sense that she had
that different culture and like yeah she
spoke a lot about her family and her
ancestry and that's kind of interesting
too so like someone who's different not
just the same girl from New York yeah or
someone who has an interesting life that
like we can look at without the drama
from the girls but it's like Barbra
lives in the same hangs out with the
same people lives in the city like a so
these women like don't their verse to
any Outsiders really which is good
they've been together for so long and
they're finally jealous like an outsider
really you can't even really come in
like Jules Weinstein never stood a
chance it's so true
but Tinsley does because people are
interested in Tinsley herself and when
people knew Tinsley before like Tinsley
existed before housewives we will talk
about the tin yeah they need like
another they need like an Adele they
know or did you watch during that watch
what happens I know it's gonna tell her
yes her real estate broker was
bartending and she was being like I
first I cute and likes like salty and
then she was being like thirsty like
talking [ __ ] about all the women and
it's clear she wants to be a housewife
and maybe she'd be good because she
knows all of them right dude we have to
be doctor sharing easy oh my god but she
would never do it she's too like a rich
yeah she doesn't need the show no she
doesn't and it would affect her practice
in a negative way but it's so someone
like that who like has encountered all
of the women who's a force to be
reckoned with yeah you know I'm not
really moved by the real estate agent
but no I'm just saying like that someone
like that but someone who's like less
salty and less thirsty okay and it looks
like all the shows are in a lull right
now like benefit brawls horrible
horrible even Beverly Hills like a lots
happening but nothing's happening this
episode was boring
yeah it was I barely remember what he
didn't even happened
um and Vanderpump rules like I just I
can't finish and and honestly even
though the puppy shower was like the
dumbest thing I've ever heard which bud
it was the most interesting part of the
episode because it was unbelievably
awkward like I'm cleaning and cleaning
things were happening yeah I mean we're
talking I had something to react to
totally anyways I think it's time that
we
into the five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast they'll be
your last piece of toast for eight days
oh my god we should change the name of
the show for the next eight days the
morning lots of the morning matzo done
okay we'll get a new neon sign and
everything by the time the Sun comes
Passover will be over Kelly Clarkson
shuts down Carrie Underwood Feud rumors
with hilarious tweet okay so I guess
people are you know sticking to their
old tropes that Kelly Clarkson and
Carrie Underwood are feuding not even
people just our magazine just our
magazine which seems like okay totally
not true but like have you ever seen
them in the same room together no it's
so much in common it's so much in common
like they should feud because that's
just like what people do but at the end
of the day they both have such full
lives and there's so much going on and
it's not like I feel like they're ever
up for the same opportunity that like
Carrie gets but Kelly wanted you know
like I don't really feel that they cross
over that much they just have a lot in
common so I don't even believe this feud
at all also Kelly Clarkson is too pure
of heart to ever feud with another
fellow female agreed agreed but they
have so much in common like why don't
they ever hang out and talk about it
because just Carrie under would hang out
with anyone I don't know no she's a
family Gary thing no it's definitely
Carrie think Kelly Clarkson is like if
you want to come over to Kelly's harves
for honey and biscuits and sweet tea she
will have you over in a second but
Carrie is like her gates are closed you
know yeah my closer gates to married man
so Star Magazine has a cover secret feud
explodes between Carrie and Kelly and
Kelly Clarkson tweeted the photo and
said someone just sent me this and I'm
like why does she get the good pic and I
have the worst expression I've ever made
with zero muscles being used in my face
I officially have a feud with whoever
used this pic at least give me a good
pic if y'all are gonna be lying is all
I'm saying
okay when people in line and then some
replied Carrie and get the bad pic
because there is no pad pic of Carrie so
true not false nutballs and Kelly wrote
haha Touche well I have plenty of rough
ones but I guess it builds character and
keeps me humble this is what I tell
myself I have truly started following
Kelly Clarkson on Twitter and I have to
say like she is her personality really
shines through her Twitter like you
always know when there are celebrities
who have their teams running their
instagrams and like it's really an
authentic and you can feel like the
distance but Kelly Clarkson is the only
person with her finger on the thumb of
her Twitter and it's so obvious and it's
so great she's just always tweeting at
celebrities and if you
people are really starting tenders like
get her personality and like she's being
rewarded for it like she's hosting about
War Music Awards again where you can
find her hosting and us attending yeah
can you believe it words having the
Billboard Music Award it's attending
like attendees just just tell it like
just showing up on the carpet having
their photo taken and like taking our
seats in the back she's also getting her
own talk show oh yeah
which is gonna be premium because she's
a premium gal that's sure people are
starting to understand Kelly Clarkson
wears I feel like you've been really
understanding her for years for years
like when I said she was my dream guest
on the show like I wasn't [ __ ] around
no you were it was a rooted in like a
deep history and understanding of her as
a premium gal yeah I love a premium gal
I love a premium gown speaking of
premium gals
next up ariana grande opens up about the
dark side of performing her music quote
on Thursday the singer kept things real
when a fan tweeted music is your therapy
and I love seeing it heal you
while many expected the singer to agree
with the fans she revealed it's not
always the case
quote making it is healing performing it
is like reliving it all over again and
it is hell she since deleted that tweet
she's so fragile and she's so busy and I
just I can't stress enough like how
badly I want Ariana grounded you just
take a [ __ ] nap like here's how I
feel about all of this I got totally
understand how she feels and even as a a
fan of her is like it's like I don't
want to see I know she doesn't want a
tour and I don't want to see her tour
like I love that she's making you music
and I really do think that it's helped
her get over so much like even thank you
next it's like helps other people get
over breakups and so I think in her
writing it like it helps her heal but
there needs to be a break where like
people don't have to tour their music
you know I mean we saw it in Bohemian
Rhapsody album tour out on tour right
why can't he just be album album album
album well what's really interesting
about Coachella and not to make the
whole thing about Taylor Swift but
here's what it is is that Taylor Swift
said once you know Taylor's like the og
of writing about like and it's a
Taylor's a little bit more subtle she's
not gonna be like almost married feet
you know what I mean so but what she
says is like a lot of the songs that she
writes are like really written in like
deep states of pain and she's like upset
and the songs are like these supposed to
be this cathartic things but when you
sing them like it really it takes you
back to that moment but what she said
especially about the song all too well
which if
if you've never heard it like I truly
feel bad for you and it's I believe that
it's one of the best friend songs of our
time like I really do and did you know
that there's a 10-minute version like a
bit that she never released and like I'm
just hoping it'll come out one day it's
just I mean it's already like a six
minute song it's just like ballad it's
Charlie about Jake Gyllenhaal just when
she was such a fragile young woman just
like her heart being broken and she
performed without that award show on the
piano issues because she was banging
your head yeah so what she says that
when she wrote that song it was like
when the one of the worst times in her
life and when you sing it the first few
times it's like it brings you back to
that moment but then when you start to
tour all around the world and like hear
your fans sing it and like see how much
it means to them like now you start to
transfer that feeling to the song so
it's like now every time she plays the
song she's saying thinks of every arena
she's ever played it in where people are
like screaming crying singing the words
back to her not the moment where she was
on her bathroom floor like looking for
the refrigerator like you know
definitely but I think one like he said
she's more subtle than Ariana who
literally has to say all of her ex's
names on stage yeah songs and - I think
what Ariana has been through is
unbelievably more traumatic than Taylor
then Jake Gyllenhaal breaking up with
Taylor Swift oh for sure but pain is
pain there are levels of pain do other
than break up PTSD is worse than a
breakup yes no no for sure but what I'm
just saying it's like pain you can feel
pain and people can deal with it in a
similar way even if one is out of a
bigger bigger magnitude agreed but maybe
that her this hain isn't as
transformative as Taylor Swift's pain no
but if she performs it enough times
maybe she'll start to associate the
happy fans singing seven rings as
opposed or not so nice even take your
next to the sadness of the song you know
what I mean like at some point they just
become words yeah you know yeah and you
were not to be tricked but she always
just saw in three [ __ ] months ago
like of course she's still upset about
it you know she need to take a break she
needs to take a break like she can keep
singing writing songs cuz I think it
helps her but she must stop touring like
touring is not good for anyone Avicii
documentary you guys yeah no it's no
house we have to see it it's a touring
comic myself I know like no it's so high
ring just to like constantly be on and I
have to sing and then do a mean read and
it's like you're surrounded by like 500
people who are just there to be get paid
to tell you you're pretty and that
you're doing a good job and like it's
not real life look she needs to go home
she need to go back to Boca hang out
with
Joan and her brother and just chill
maybe not the brother thing but we saw
Frankie at Coachella like we were dying
yeah
like I was just like in in like in a
state of shock to me in this in the
presence of the biggest thirst monster
on planet Earth it's like I never
thought that you know this little girl
like me I just started on the internet
like I would never be in the same room
as the biggest thirst monster named
field but then Here I am standing three
feet from him three feet less it was
exciting yeah good times
okay there wasn't that much sub story
saying have a few good did you the
Kourtney Kardashian birthday no it's her
birthday she turned a birthday party no
oh my god okay let's make it a story
whatever whatever bad story just know
it's a good they're good stories okay
well let me just tell you okay she did a
40th birthday party and I have to say I
was very confused because I was looking
at simon huck stories and he was
videoing her blowing out her cake and i
thought it was from an old birthday
party cuz i stopped going on ashley Anna
wearing the same exact thing she awarded
the Gatsby party she wear the long
sequined dress and the headpiece member
I was so confused I thought it was a
throwback but she literally wore the
exact same thing was it a themed party
well all the girls were wearing sparkle
so I don't know if it was a theme but
[ __ ] Kylie looked amazing she was
wearing a sparkly gold banjo and then a
sparkly gold skirt that like went from
right under the Mentos all the way to
the floor so it looked like a dress but
there was like a couple inches of skin
and she looked amazing there's a video
of her dancing with Chris and first of
all she is the worst dancer but she
looked like she was having a good time
and from the back she just looked so
[ __ ] snatch like you've never seen a
body like that in your life long black
hair like just a regular Kylie bides wow
I gotta check it out it's how did the
party look fun okay the party was poppin
who sang her happy birthday Robin Thicke
and a woman and I was like who the [ __ ]
is this woman I she looked so familiar I
couldn't figure it out and you want to
know why cuz it was SIA
she sounded amazing like Robin Thicke
was thirsting out with his vocal trails
and was like please let's see I have her
moment and then she did and she sounded
so good wow that's pretty cool pretty
much everyone was there there's a video
of Kendall like laying down on French
Montana and I just like have so many
thoughts on French Montana like how he's
been such a good friend to the family
but also dating Kylie ad Chloe yeah but
honestly like he they only keep people
in the loop who they can trust and it's
apparent that no matter what happens
with French Montana he's always been a
good friend to the family and I think
someone should date him but who who's it
Courtney or Kendall
get like maybe he was the one that got
away maybe but apparently like
like she wasn't it wasn't good but they
keep him around so he's a good guy yeah
Paris was there obviously that is
someone okay I have to go luck Kim did
great stories oh and they had edged they
had custom 1942 bottles of tequila and
they had a like on the back it was like
itched in the glass a picture of Cortney
and it said the most interesting to look
at that's hilarious and so and the
napkins and the napkins cocktail napkin
said Kim there are people that are dying
as much as we talked about Kourtney like
she really looks amazing at 40 and I
feel like all the Kardashian senior
women so like the the three are really
like changing what it means like to turn
for it to be a woman in their 40s or a
woman in your late 30s like they're all
having babies now they look the best
that they've ever loved successful
businesses they're in their prime and
typically like you as women all we hear
is like you know you'll never be this
young or this pretty right and it's like
according to the Kardashians no I'm only
about to get like better-looking it goes
up more successful and more fertile and
have something controversial to say so
you know push put together this like
video of all the people in Kourtney's
sights like wishing her happy birthday
so I went to the Instagram to look at it
and I was looking at the Instagram of
like they're just like the past week of
content like natural products home
remedy is whatever in the comments like
there's so many comments of people being
like well I'm so happy this website
exists like I know Kourtney like I've
always respected Kourtney for how much
she you know in does natural whatever
for her kids and it takes care of her
family like I'm so loving all this
information I think push is gonna be a
success actually I think it's already a
success and the only thing that she
needs to do to make it successful is to
be consistent and keep doing it right
because like how many she doesn't be
consistently boring how many fans of the
Kardashians have let's say 100 million
Kim has more followers than that even if
1% of those fans only 1% love Kourtney
who's a success you know it's 1 million
people tuning in to peace it's shaping
up to be a big they're gonna sell it
till I can't even ask for some [ __ ] I
don't think that they should I think
that she should just keep doing what
she's doing with her affiliate links
totally well what else happened a
birthday party uh I'll have to chin to
the story yeah Kanye was there there's
like pigs there's so funny there's a
picture of Kanye like all this Fred's
like looking big and macho and like
Kourtney in the front and then right
after there's another one where they
obviously made Kourtney get out because
it's the same picture but without
Courtney probably like ran in and
actually a picture of her running into
be was her birthday so they couldn't
kick her out but he's like get out she
was wearing sparkles actually though but
Kim was wearing black with sparkles
clothes wearing sparkles Kylie's wearing
sparkles I didn't see Kendall but it was
kind of like Bethany's dinner in her
house yeah oh my god Bethany looked
amazing I mean look they were all just
dressed up to like sit in her kitchen it
was weird it was weird
it's her old apartment me too and that
scene with the ex that was so funny that
was so funny and so awkward and at first
they didn't address what was wrong with
her face and I was like maybe she just
has that skin that she's like I just got
a facial like okay that makes sense but
it's like they weren't addressing it no
it makes a lot of sense
your ex is [ __ ] hot yeah she gets the
hottest guys my hair is like yeah she
couldn't believe it either but it's like
they all got so and I get what Bethany
was trying to do like have her new home
like make it a fancy affair but like it
was just the six of them literally
sitting in her kitchen she should have
had more people like him just like
random or at least invite the husband's
like something cuz he was at the end of
the day was six women in sparkles like
sitting on the roaring like Tinsley wore
a gorgeous dress what a waste
so Neela bet you the fall outfit like
what a we definitely looked amazing I
love Bethany with long straight hair me
too
all dressed up with nowhere to go no
truly it was so weird and then Barbara
like Barbara needs a style overhaul like
wouldn't Barbara showed up in a crop
tops in the Berkshires I was so confused
you know what I was confused about the
weather they're swimming they're wearing
sweaters yeah and boots they're working
out it's Halloween I couldn't like what
it must have been so they think it's
fall vibes so they came in their fall
clothes and then it was like 70 degrees
we're really on Halloween what was the
temperature I was in Austin was it and I
think it was doing shows I was in Boston
oh no what you wouldn't know what the
weather up here was no I don't remember
um sorry yeah we're getting sidetracked
okay
next story is a delicious-looking story
that i just had to share with you I hop
isn't it now I hob that was a prank
no yeah no mm-hmm they should get really
far like they had Jonathan Cheban they
hired him like to do the whole thing it
was brick oh I didn't see that part I
just like spread the news and I assumed
okay I hop is introducing cinnamon
churro pancakes topped with mini churros
yeah that picture honestly just a little
chairs on top look good yeah no I oh
that looks so good there are no IHOP's
in the city I haven't been to one in
like years since we went to camp
but would you have to tell everyone
about our transformative Applebee's
experience oh my god wait in addition to
this churro pancakes they're also doing
Italian cannoli pancakes in honor of the
Italian camper it's really a slow news
day for a Mexican tres leche pancakes
I'm sorry this symbol Alysha s' oh and
after my experience at Applebee's I will
definitely be trying more franchises
well so I mean I I spend a lot of time
and like the outskirts of New York just
like me better always gonna like Target
or like whatever we just take the car
like we go places so I'm normal and I've
been to an Applebee's but there are no
Applebee's in the city or there's one
and it's in Times Square so it's like
you just can't get there but when we're
at Coachella
we left the festival a little bit early
cuz we had to go to some extra parties
but we needed to get something to eat
first me with Amanda Stanton and we were
like looking for a place to eat but
Coachella is like the [ __ ] desert
there's nothing that there's nothing
there but it's also grandma villa
apparently everything goes awry my veil
everything closes at 10:00 so I looked
at my phone there was an Applebee's and
like I think Jackie any minute we're
like a little reluctant I've never been
to one but I said you guys Applebee's
first of all has the best fountain soda
and it has open bar so we needed to keep
drinking but not open bar it has a bar
bar but we need a full bar yeah we have
to we had to eat and like relax we also
needed a place to change into our
outfits but we also needed to like drink
and keep the party going and honestly I
can't stress enough like how going to
Applebee's was the best call I've ever
made the best decision we made all
weekend we made all weekend first of all
it was so clean like we went to the
bathroom and we all change I like it was
not disgusting I left my backpack on the
floor like I didn't care so it they
hosted us in their bathroom quarters
before they even knew we were gonna be
real customers then it was like busy but
not so much you couldn't get a table we
sat immediately in this huge booth and
we ordered like the fattest things ever
and we asked to wait just for
recommendation did she happen to
recommend the best item ever and I
usually like hate waitress
recommendations like how do you know who
I am like you don't know me you don't
know but I like what you recommend in
the beer cheese and pretzel [ __ ]
phenomenal you guys it was the most I
Love New York City it was the most
salacious off pretzel I've ever had in
my life we had the pretzel we had
mozzarella sticks we had chicken fingers
we had spinach artichoke dip yes okay
pretzel was the best pretzel was the
best for me the mozzarella stick was the
worst I don't know why it was just like
there there are a million good
mozzarella sticks in this country like
you don't need to go to Applebee's for
it didn't it didn't strike a chord for
me then second best for me with spinach
artichoke and I couldn't eat chicken
fingers but I
anything other than the [ __ ] pretzels
and beer cheese oh and then we all got
like tequila sodas and we were like well
if I was done eating that by the time we
paid the check like our drinks were full
so they gave us to go cups it was just
such a fantastic experience I can't
stress enough like how much I love
Applebee's it's definitely like it's
definitely now number two or three on my
favorite chain restaurants cuz number
one is probably CPK number two is
Cheesecake Factory so number three is
Applebee's
when me and Margo we're in Greensboro we
wanted to you know taste the local
cuisine you know get a feel for the
indigenous culture and we went to Apple
anywhere to Cheesecake master egg fries
I think yep Cheesecake Factory and I
would like I made a huge mistake at
Cheesecake Factory so I knew what I
wanted but then I took a look at the
skinny delicious menu cuz like Margo was
ordering from the skinny menu did she
order salad what did you veggie burger
yes so I found something on the skinny
lucious menu like it's an appetizer that
I was gonna get and if you know me you
know I've literally never eaten an
appetizer in my life like I get to a
restaurant and I just eat like every
time people order appetizers they're
just no appetizers that were catered to
my needs
yeah so there was an appetizer on there
that I kind of like was it - it was like
a chicken lettuce wrap which I really do
like like but not as a meal it's not
nearly as hearty enough so we're
ordering Margo ordered and I said to
pretend like okay I'm gonna start with
the the chicken lettuce wraps it's like
okay then he closes his book and walks
away so like I'm not gonna be like so
embarrassing like actually I wanted more
so I ended up with just the chicken
lettuce wraps and you want to hear some
hunted him down
I had the calories on there there were
so low calorie you want to know why
there was one piece of chicken in every
taco but what would you have ordered for
you mean I was gonna get a sandwich yeah
but it's on the point of the story
actually the point of my story was I
wanted to tap on you for like some some
creative resources because me and lardo
go everywhere and like people always
they're telling us Kota like this Creek
Mexican ice we only go to chains like
because I like to discover and they're
chains like in Texas water burger that I
didn't know about so like I did and I
also just love chains they're so
reliable like a PF Changs like I just I
love it so I'm thinking for my next tour
the journey jeans tour will be over in
January we're figuring out the rest of
the dates I'm coming all your cities
don't worry but I want the next tour to
be like the great American food chain
tour I just like a good name for it so I
wanted you to help me okay I'm not gonna
think maybe like sponsored by Applebee's
you know yeah but I just think it's like
a good name for a tour and it's like
really true I literally go and I just
eat a chains okay I'll think about it
okay
or like the Eternity chain scrubs given
to me by Chester if you have a comment
you want to drop one
let me know like the great American food
tour but like I wanted to be I want the
word chain in there okay
Cheney dives you know Dick Cheney I
don't know Cheney vibes only yeah yeah
ah next step little business really
exciting not exciting sorry but
interesting factoids that are
interesting and you know these tech
unicorn stocks that are going public
some are flopping snap some are not
IPO day was yesterday for Pinterest Oh
in public and zoom and it ends with
shares sharply higher did really whoa
zoom is a video conferencing company of
for corporate America that'll do well
and that's where you would like to share
the McKenzie file I think it's so weird
that Pinterest just went public because
there was a heyday of Pinterest like
five years ago if there ever was a time
for it to have been at its height no I
think it's actually better than a twin
pop book now cuz the heyday that was
like people everyone joined and then a
lot of people left but now it has a very
consistent user base it is what it is
it's weddings it's inspo its style it's
all of that and so now if it had gone
public then it would have dropped
immediately because people stopped like
it had a peak and then it pitted but now
it's so consistent that it's it knows
what it is and you can buy stocks in it
it's not going to change anytime soon
yes that's true it's just like so weird
like of all the social media tools like
I forgot about Pinterest yeah I mean I'm
not a pillar of another Pinner
um but I'm had like people who are
interesting like nice people like no
one's leaving like mean comments on
Pinterest oh no not at all the rush of
so called unicorn startups toward the
public markets had a rocky start but
Thursday indicated that investors remain
eager to get a piece of them shares in
Pinterest the digital pin Bert pin board
jumped over 20% on its first day of
trading as a public company the
company's stock began trading at twenty
three dollars and seventy five cents
above the initial public offering price
of $19.48 Remora tail chains
honestly that sounds crazy but that when
you think about it and you've ever been
to Macy's or Nordstrom recently makes a
lot of sense no it makes the most sense
especially on the Macy's from more
important to investors the price put the
company's value above its last private
valuation of twelve billion dollars
avoiding a disappointing outcome that
makes that's so crazy
usually they all these Silicon Valley
startups they have these crazy
valuations ten billion dollars for a
company that's never made any money
right turns out it's worth twelve
billion right no that's very cool I'm
happy for Pinterest and zoom a video
conferencing company also went public to
tremendous investor demand on Thursday
it's because the investors use you know
they need it the investors never heard
of Pinterest right shares in the company
which was last value by private
investors at 1 billion dollars the
threshold for unicorn status among
private startups skyrocketed eighty
percent in early trading the shares
ended the day up more than 72 percent
closing at $62 the company's fully
diluted market capitalization now
exceeds 18 billion starting at 1 billion
this isn't making me so mad because we
have some proprietary technology here
where's my 18 billion dollars I know but
it's like I'm like I watched too much
American greed and so stocks are just
sometimes like so volatile so volatile
the stock market is just it's crazy out
there
underrated ly like gambling and also
it's like once you go public then you
have to start answering to people and
that's the thing about Sarah notes they
never went public so they never had to
explain what the [ __ ] they were doing
this is like an episode of Drop Dead
Diva this guy he had started he had made
himself a company that went public and
all of his shareholders were allowed to
like decide what he does like what is he
for breakfast but he fell in love with
this woman and the shareholders didn't
approve sweet to get himself like out of
this contract that's like oh that's
funny yeah so that's like Jeff Bezos
like the shareholders really can control
your life right even though like Jeff
Bezos isn't the company he's just the
creator of the company so he should be
there should be like a level of distance
but people are obsessed people are
obsessed but truly like I go on
amazon.com and nothing that Jen faced it
was sex to his girlfriend affects my
user it's very you know and I don't
think there's literally anything that
could happen that would make me stop
using Amazon unless unless in some way
someone told me that Jeff Beecher was to
feature that's my friend Jeff Bezos Jeff
Bezos was the confirmed
reincarnated spirit of Hitler that is
the only way I would stop using Amazon
yeah I neither then how do you get
confirmation you know even let's just
say in some way like it was 100
like actually Hitler knew Hitler was
okay Hitler could never die and he
escaped came to America shaves his head
okay and his beer and became Japanese no
or like instead of that because he would
be a hundred years old
it would be Jeff P he's just like his
leak text like words like uh you know
final final plan you know how to kill
all the Jews right honestly I don't know
I just like really love Amazon and I
guess I'm still be using Amazon like on
my way to my death
no there's like very few things I could
find like Amazon is so deeply integrated
like even for we're gonna stagecoach and
it's Passover I mean you don't eat
non-kosher meat so like we need to stock
our house with so much food I went to
Institute I went to like all these
things with grocery delivery paint
whatever Amazon one prime pantry it's
just the most efficient I just the best
efficient efficiency yeah that's what
they should have called it okay feed
them vinyl story do they ever say how
they came up with the word Amazon gets
is it's amazing amazing I don't think I
don't know I guess if I was starting a
tech coming I just like the row pick a
bunch of one word out of the bowl read
the word you know it's like okay if I
was turning a technology that was great
for like medical whatever I would call
it like feed up you know like you just
put word like letters together yeah I'm
sorry I'm having um who thoughts now
about your new tour oh okay because I'm
now I'm thinking like chains I'm
thinking breaker of chains Daenerys
Targaryen okay so maybe like an evening
with Claudia are a mother of theö
purveyor of chains see we're just
rebranding though it's not an evening
with girl Fojo anymore it's just a
Claudia trait like I say my you would
see that Amy Schumer Claudia are alive
mmm no but I'm we're trying to explain
who you are maybe just mother of the oh
no but I wants me the name of the tour
mother of theö purveyor of chains kind
of sort of chains Explorer of chains oh
that's good
but I want the name of the tour to be
the chain thing okay and we're all
across America trying America it's other
diners drive-ins and dives like maybe
like but the chain Edition maybe inside
like two chains like all chains yeah
right but is that is that conveying the
message like no it requires someone
having seen a service it's too subtle
yeah um that's right like the great
American food tour okay
I'm trying to think now I'm stuck on it
chains veins brains
Claudia Shea all brains all chains no
brains all chains
that's better but still when you think
chains like are you thinking like silver
like metal chains okay but like the okay
okay that's what the word food has to be
in there right the great American food
chain no wait no food chain is like
animals yeah yeah
the great Claudia sorry the great
American honestly that works
so it's hello okay fifth story crazy
news craze it is the Weather Channel
live broadcast was interrupted for two
hours due to a malicious software attack
Oh federal law WC mm-hmm federal law
enforcement is investigating the attack
the network said The Weather Channel's
morning show a.m. HQ America's morning
headquarters excuse me this is America's
morning heavy where I displeased they're
probably very early where America's late
yeah that's true millennium morning when
dark Thursday morning due to a malicious
quote software attack the cable network
announced the same day on Twitter the
live broadcast of the show which airs
from 5:00 a.m.
gasp to 9:00 a.m. Eastern Time was
interrupted around 6:00 a.m. and
replaced with heavy rescue or 1 we're a
suppose someone just explained to Amazon
the logo is a and Z it's everything from
A to Z so I guess the logo needed to do
something with a and Z okay sorry try to
think of more other options we
experience issues with this morning's
live broadcast following an incident we
were able to restore live programming
quickly through backup mechanism ok two
hours well no for two hours they played
heavy rescue 401 while they were
figuring out who maliciously attacked
them who the [ __ ] would detect the
Weather Channel like this sounds like a
prank and now I now I think of
everything in terms of like Lisa
Vanderpump radar Online who benefits
from this maybe people who are like
really uh like oh my god I know who was
it was Angie
from Desperate Housewives she was like a
crazy environmentalist made a bomb you
know
it's her it's someone who like really
wants to be an iron
and they don't think the Weather Channel
is doing enough to promote like the
protecting of the climate yeah maybe it
was honestly Leonardo DiCaprio chasing
them out geez honestly there's so many
people who have like a gripe with the
Weather Channel Jason Momoa shave his
beard to draw attention to protecting
art and they didn't do enough so he had
to hack the Weather Channel
yeah like the weather channel is Weather
Channel even a channel like on TV
honestly considering they obviously have
a weak software we should hack them in
stream our show live to millions of
Americans
we need a hacker if you hack hit me up
don't joke haha whatever man watching
come come for me government right take
it - they've already taken everything
from us it's so true I've no money in my
checking account I don't actually I need
to go like do a show like I need some
money
that was our fifth and final story and
now let's recap Real Housewives of New
York and you know what I have a a deep
connection to the realism Housewives of
New York now everything mines deeper
ever since Bethenny made you a cameo yes
I'm just like super deep if you guys
don't know we've partnered with cameo
like starting a week ago on the toast
and in exchange for like us working with
them they were like you can get a cameo
for hope from whoever you want so
obviously we picked like the most
unreasonable people and sent and they
actually got it they got Jackie video
from Daymond John and they got me one
for Bethenny and she was like promoting
her book in the end it was so funny and
now I just feel like every time I watch
how some like I can't watch you some
friends with these people you know right
totally
I loved receiving a cameo I loved making
cameos I'm on cameo snitches on cameo if
you don't know what cameo is it's the
best gift gift ever
so cameo makes custom videos from your
favorite celebrities you tell them like
main talking points and they make like a
wonderful premium video for you or your
friend I've asked so many people to be
their bridesmaids matrons of Honor
that's so cute like what makes someone
ask me to propose for them oh my god
I got my treasure so many happy birthday
videos so many just like good luck with
Law School videos any sort of videos
it's such a great gift having received
one I can attest to the fact that it's a
wonderful gift and you guys should all
really try it also it's like an easy
gift and like it looks super thoughtful
yeah it looks like you really went out
near a visit Kamio dot-com to receive
20% off any cameo by entering our promo
code toasters toas te RS I think I
spelled that right
kami
komm premium is held really great gift I
love receiving them I love making them
and I can't recommend it highly enough
and the snitch is there so if anyone
like needs to make a video for a camper
there's councillor snitch okay wait
people are coming with good
recommendation kind chains planes and
automobiles hmm okay
the open jean store like the unbuttoned
jean store that's funny but um true
symbol it requires too much previous
knowledge okay that's it okay
the grid American food chain what about
the grab spoon tour because saying
you're grabbing spoon at all these
chains that's good too
I just feel like I made up grab a spoon
such a long time ago and it's still
pertinent don't get me wrong like it's
very much a part of my everyday
vernacular but I like want to keep
evolving and I feel like if I'm naming
my next tour up with something I made up
two years ago but also you should see
what the material is for your next well
that's so true I should write the show
first I should also finish this first
right to figure out what the thesis of
the show is and then we come up with the
name based on that yeah what's your the
thesis I can't imagine writing another
show like I put my entire life's work
into the show every story of mine like
every well you're gonna be doing your
next tour in at least a year from now
yeah I have to have a lot of time to a
lot of life to live a lot of life to
live new experiences new see ceases on
the on the world is it these scissors
Macy's I don't know I guess you should
the point is to only have one thesis you
know oh that's true like it's it's not
something that should be plural it's an
oxymoron to have multiple thesis EES
exactly of what if I said all of you
guys had wonderful thesis ease these I I
don't know these all of you guys I like
to each and every one a partner I had a
really hard time today on my Instagram
it's my friend's birthday and they're
twins so I was like it's my friends is
birthdays in torture yeah it was really
confusing yeah sorry guys that's tough
okay Real Housewives of New York just
give us one best snoozefest Berkshires
looked like we had seen all of it on
Bethenny's Instagram so I guess right
and it was more fun on Instagram yeah
and they just used her videos and I
thought it was kind of cool how they
they acknowledge that everyone had seen
these videos and so then they were just
like recapping it like that yeah well
and then like Barbara really just like
didn't make like
I feel as though when Barbara came on to
the season I really liked her out of the
gate you too and then every episode I'd
like to heard less and less and and now
I see why she it didn't ever became a
full and honestly like people are being
so mean about to our newsroom and she
got really fed up with Barbara and she
should have liked it was so mean and was
so [ __ ] up
it was so [ __ ] up in Steven and
Dorinda was totally right like LuAnn
literally told her what to say because
they were repeating each other like look
Joe and Barbara's never been to this
house she doesn't know that this is like
a room like it's a thing and she like
came in just with full knowledge of what
was going on because LuAnn briefed her
100%
also trinda had every right to be mad
like that is such a [ __ ] up like don't
come into my house and told everything
but then what Dorinda said at Bethenny's
dinner when she was like just digging
her heels in at Barbara like I'm like if
you were mad at the moment you had every
right to me and you should have said
something then but like a week later or
if you are a man at the table say you're
mad at the table they don't throw in
these like passive-aggressively shabana
crumbs it was really uncalled for and it
was like taking it a little too far I'm
like why does Barbara LuAnn did the same
thing at a larger level she actually
didn't even stay in the room that's
right
she insulted it so why are you saying
equal things to LuAnn when LuAnn was
like in the room while Tinsley was still
packing up her bag like LuAnn was being
so out of control and like I'm a LuAnn
Stan and Elena polishes but like even I
can't come up with a good defense of
this no and like her not respecting
Bethenny and not understanding like that
she she's not in a position to say one
cross word about Bethenny not at all I'm
the Bethenny fully is like emulated
that's so perfectly look why she's
saying anything negative everybody
whatsoever like in any capacity right
and she doubles down on like it's not
just like she threw a tantrum she said
some crazy stuff when they're getting
their hair down and she's like Bethenny
Bethenny Bethenny she's like making fun
of Bethenny again if I were Bethenny and
I watched that like I'd be [ __ ]
pissed and you know what and I don't
know if I've ever said this but I do
know that when LuAnn was in a lot of
legal trouble in Palm Beach it was
Dennis who helped her out um yeah they
sat down the show yeah but not that he
got her a lawyer it was like on a much
higher level I believe like and also
when she was like relapsing again right
it was it was if Linda has a lot to be
indebted to Bethenny a lot a lot and I
just can't win Ramona it was like the
average American girl is huge I just
caught up on two episodes like Ramona
has just a way of saying something
that's like so [ __ ] up when she says
it's like
cuz it's remote like you have to accept
people for who they are and like not
trying change them and at the end of the
day what she was saying is something
that you were anyone would say because
it's a fact is that like we have no VC
obesity problem in America but the way
that Ramona said it it's just like so
offensive but it's hilarious like that's
why she's on TV that's why she's the
only housewife on New York who has
withstood every single season and full
cast member yeah so like for that I'm
appreciative of Ramona I got a great
laugh out of it and also you don't touch
the [ __ ] Morgan letters letters
letters but they shown you is giving me
camille Grammer vibes
because at both dinners the women were
like talking passionately and then just
started crying well that was because
Sonia was so dry so wasted you know what
it's like Sonia really doesn't drink
anymore so like everyone acting like
Sonia spiraling you know what she
doesn't drink she's out with her friends
and she's in a safe space she's in a
house like there's nothing bad that can
happen to she's not gonna get arrested
like let her live no and I feel like the
women do let her live like they whenever
she drinks a lot they're not like you
need to stop drinking they're like
worried you need to stop drinking for
your life they're like you need to drink
water right now we need to get you
through this but it's not like they sit
down with her the next morning they're
like you have to stop drinking yeah like
I love Sonja so much and clearly she
went into a warp in that house and it
was like so subscribe ties it and she
couldn't get out of it until after she
had to cry about the Morgan letters you
don't touch the phone matter no she's so
funny and she's so pure and she's
looking really good I liked her green
dress she let's go to the sparkly dinner
I just like I love her she can do no
wrong she provides such like a light
breezy Sun baibe to the franchise
without start having to start drama yeah
I like Bethenny's house a lot I have a
lot of thoughts on it I love that she
has like that glam alcove yeah you know
and she gets her glammed up in class oh
the glove oh it's just so interesting
how it's not a doorman building which is
like unheard of on Real Housewives of
New York you know yeah
but like it's still like a ten million
dollar apartment but just interesting
it's it's it's just a little like
industrial for my taste
yeah I like I like the way it's
decorated I just loved her last
apartment so much I thought it was the
perfect home which one oh yeah with the
big bar yeah that was like had the Pops
of red yeah yeah it was a great
apartment so I'm just I'm lamenting I
didn't understand why she moved so I
can't like move past it did she ever
sell that one oh yeah they got full
member her and
oh the bar yeah yeah Fredrik anyways
apparently that guy there's more to come
this season
so [ __ ] suck it but you know what
wasn't being said was that it's not the
cheats afraid to call her boyfriend she
just want to do it on camera I'm sure he
doesn't even like filming that much like
and it's like embarrassing I totally got
that for sure but and I understand if
she was like no I'm not doing that she's
so boring no cheese dare and second of
all don't choose jitter if you like art
okay if you didn't want to call Ben on
camera he would've been like [ __ ] you
guys I'm not doing it like she got so
defensive and like quivery and weird
about it that like spokes it's a much
bigger problem than their relations cuz
the next episode she's saying that
they're not together anymore
and I used to ship them so hard it's
like a john cena nikki bella thing and
now I'm like please separate and if her
being with him would mean that she
hasn't moved to Chicago she can't be a
Real Housewife of New York there's no
Real Housewives of Chicago so she would
have to be give up everything for him
and like I I don't think that she should
but she needs to [ __ ] grow up she's
such a baby even when she sat down with
LuAnn and just started crying before
they go oh my god and like it's like
it's big and LuAnn feels so bad it was
the weirdest thing it was that was a
really weird and it was like I really
want to like Tinsley and like I'm
rooting for her and but it's now this is
her third season and she hasn't evolved
or matured or like just moved forward
yeah or grown like she came in like a
little quivering cowering child totally
understandable but she's still that
person you know who I'm having like a
weird conflicted feeling about let me
guess it has to be some of them we
haven't spoken about or is it Dorinda
stirring though because I had such a
vengeance of hate in my heart for her at
the end of last season like she was on
the wrong side of history like on
Carroll side Carroll was such a mean
girl but she like came for Bethany in
such an evil way for literally no reason
other than to be on Carroll side at the
Reunion and everyone was gay Ramona to
like everyone was ganging up on Bethany
and like she really held her own but
like for no reason and now she bet that
I mean now Dorinda is being like so
weirdly nice to Bethany and I appreciate
it but I'm just like confused by it and
I really like them together and there is
a part of Dorinda that's like so
maternal like when she's in the
Berkshire she really embraces her inner
host she was taking care of everyone I'm
like I see why people like her and like
I was really digging her especially when
she was defending Bethenny like
wholeheartedly without question but
there's a part of her that is so
inherently like
evil and I'll never forget the way that
I felt at that reunion you know no and
like there's a part of her that makes no
[ __ ] sense like the way she was
talking about LuAnn for the first few
episodes like was soaking Barbara out of
her house was so backwards and then the
way she acted in the birch chairs was
like so mature and so I really do go
back and forth also in like sometimes in
her side commentary like she makes the
most sense and other times I'm like like
this is cruel yeah but she did say being
in this season she's not drinking and I
think that in this moment in the
Berkshires she's still not drinking I
don't know if she is right now but I
think in that woman she's still very
lucid like everyone was getting [ __ ]
up she really wasn't speaking about
drinking great transition to Vanderpump
rules um which for me is just like 10
minutes a week no it's so bad I love I
just love lolly like her not drinking
and like everything that she feels about
drinking is so relatable like and it's
so crazy because so many of the cast
have real like I'm not gonna say that
they have like drinking problems but
drinking affects their lives in a
negative way and they have a negative
relationship with alcohol and like they
drink and bad things happen but then
they drink again and it's just a cycle
and it's also their job and it's really
it's really complicated and I've never
thought that Lola even add her like
panic attack I never thought that she
would be the first person to turn away
from alcohol and I think it's like the
I'm sure it's so hard for she's
literally young Hollywood really miss
everything works in a restaurant like
all the whole runs the gamut and for her
not to make the decision not to drink
anymore like I just think it's like so
strong ya know I'm like wow I could be
as strong I don't know if I could be as
strong but like I totally and then she
was on watch what happens live talking
about it and when she had that
conversation with scheana that was over
the summer and then she said she had a
few more benders after that before she
stopped during he on October 22nd it was
like the best day of her life yeah and I
just like I have so much respect for her
Sam I mean I just love her the show is
so boring like the fact that Tom
Schwartz getting the cash was like a
full storyline is so sad the fact that
the episode was called The Exorcism of
Stassi shorter when it was the last five
minutes and that woman was [ __ ] crazy
she look like Sara Bareilles it also
it's like I love sassy and I'm sure this
was just a storyline but to like the
average viewer it's like okay you have
you have a lot of like issues trust
issues that are very founded and like
things that have happened to you and
that wouldn't maybe you would think like
maybe you go to therapy you're like do
something but inside you got an exorcism
like that's such a joke it's actually
very brave of Brittany and Jack's like
go to couples Council on TV like I don't
know like if I ever like was in couples
counseling like I feel like I would
never even want to talk about it let
alone on television yeah very brave very
very brave
there's Jack's has always been brave
like that he's always sharing even with
the raki it was weird but he wouldn't
deep but he was shared it on television
yeah and he's always being honest maybe
to a fault like in next week's episode
where he tells Brittany's family that
he's and I'm the wrong guy in this
relationship he's double the number one
guy in the group I'll give him that
he is I I just I love them and I think
also he does a lot of this stuff because
he still recognizes his role on being
I'm a TV show but also doesn't want to
ruin his life right so like these are
things he can apologize for to Kristen
and Ariana of it all was actually
probably the most interesting part of
the episode because you don't know that
story that one aren't on his dad died
like Kristen was bullying her that day
and like it's actually super impressive
that Kristen can own that cuz like you
have to be really mature to own the fact
like you were once a complete piece of
[ __ ] and I was really impressed by that
I was impressed by you too and I think
it's like when we watched it ariana
wasn't a cast member she was just this
girl who tom was flirting with no one
ever really hated Ariana but inherently
we're gonna take Chris inside because we
were only seeing Krista side of it right
because we know her more but I just
think it's such a good lesson and like
who was it recently who came on to a new
show and we automatically took the other
person side Oh
uncia sticky mmm where we automatically
hate Kara because like we love Juliet
but like Juliet did some things that
like weren't great and like I could see
us watching this back in hindsight even
though at the end I've not caught up on
Siesta Key member or even Teresa and
Melissa Gorga when Melissa he does it we
just hated Melissa because we because
Dan Teresa but like Melissa didn't do
anything wrong and like Teresa was
really like being mean to her yeah you
know so I just feel like hindsight is
20/20 but also it's like it should
affect how we like how we act now you
know great it's not just be oh that's an
interesting factoid that's well
interesting like just because someone's
a full cast member and someone's not
doesn't mean me automatically should
take their side is it alls I'm saying
yeah and then Lala's performance which I
just loved ya know I just loved I loved
I just loved people expressing the
selves you know yeah she was just being
so cute and cute and emotional and
talented and beautiful she had a record
deal I think we would have heard about
it right but it's like I just loved the
level that she's at if she gets any
bigger like she'll she'll flee the nest
just lolly ya know what her she is like
the perfect level of Fame I feel like
she's one of the most well respected
people on the show you know she like
gets really like good press and like
people are always wanting to talk to her
yeah and I hope she likes stays
level-headed she was on watch what
happens live like for me she comes she
with she was with Ariana and all they
talked about the whole time was like
them honking up in the car and it was
like kind of annoying because like
there's a whole season of Mother Earth
um but to me like she really can do or
say no wrong like I'll apologize for her
like till the death I think she's like
one of the best people that's ever been
on television too but she was being kind
of salty I watch what happens like she
said she didn't know who they are
getting spark was was actually really
funny and then she was like I had a
raquel mome and it's like don't throw
raquel under the bus just cuz you [ __ ]
up that's mean
I agree that was like the one thing that
bothered me because like she really goes
in on our counting James and for the
most part I'm here for it no but like
house not even in the room James really
deserves it like if you want to go down
on James and everything you say be a
little jab towards them you know I'm
okay with that but like Rock Hill at the
end of the day never did anything other
than like James with like jazz and like
not have the highest of IQs right no
it's C you just did what well I love it
no but I wasn't we're talking about her
so we don't know that she is I'm a lot
higher you and I believe should find out
it's like you know I agree I don't like
that um let's start my Beverly Hills
even though there's truly like nothing
to say okay the episode started with
what
Oh Kyle go to the grocery store oh those
cute I like that car - I want one a
little dangerous and she's [ __ ]
texting as she's right on the phone I
was a kid and also it's like you were
production with you so like they have a
van they could have cared he could have
taken new groceries ya know it was cute
though I love Kyle's house I just love
seeing like more of her life unfold she
said such an interesting character
because she really like over the course
of the eight years she's been on TV like
their finances have just grown so much
and I love watching her girl from this
house to this house and then that car to
that car and this bag to that bag
they're moving on up yeah it's nice it's
nice of them also the bridal shower
which was like super cute oh yeah they
also had ill CLO and Lisa Vanderpump
didn't come in and said she wasn't
invited
and I agree with Kyle that's really
annoying of command to be like oh I
didn't know that well other than I mean
Camille might I mean she should have
said like there was a place for you at
the table so I was assuming they didn't
just like caulk I'll be like hey did you
remember Lisa yeah yeah okay Lisa Booker
says were invited but Camille's so
weirdly in the middle on this whole Lisa
Vanderpump thing that cuz she doesn't
want to be on the wrong side again yeah
yeah even though it seems like she's
taking the wrong side yeah erica was
like not in this episode whatsoever but
when that guy knocked her out I like
felt so bad for the guy it's like that
is the worst feeling like not only did
you knock someone out like you're not
talking your boss yeah on TV great and
she said who was that Jim he was like it
was me oh my god uh yeah I didn't
realize that she was that she was very
much missed this she didn't go to the
shower and then she did go to the gym
dinner and then the dinner was
interesting on many levels like Kim
Richards was in the place Kim Richards
was in the place analyze that marina
like has deep eyes and when he heard I
didn't know it was still so pertinent to
know and that the last time they saw
each other was with the bunny and Rinna
and Kyle are such good friends yeah it's
just it's complicated
oh and then Kathy Hilton was there yes
yeah I know it was all very very weird
and like even the relationship with it
between Lisa and Kim definitely takes a
toll on Lisa because Lisa's mom knew
about it
like they were talking about it like
she's heavily spoken about but like it's
still a pertinent real thing I mean she
must get over it because like she's on
the show Kim's not move on everyone took
your side like just move on but uh
clearly she has she's just gonna milk it
and then there was a political
discussion at the table which is such a
rarity and had two things to say one I
really commend both Lisa Vanderpump and
camille Grammer everybody Rinna
whatever Lisa Rinna for having like a
civilized conversation even though they
couldn't been on more polar opposite
sides and neither one of them were
agreeing on anything like that is how
you have a civil discourse right to
Camille Grammer comparing like the mean
tabloid things people said about her to
being falsely accused of sexual assault
is literally the most craziest thing
ever and just not real yeah no it wasn't
it was a stretch of a comparison Brett
Kavanaugh but I guess it's like you know
she was comparing yourself to someone
who's like been canceled or I don't know
I it was a stretch it was a stretch but
then like her crying at the bottom of
the staircase and asking Kyle to be her
bridesmaid like what if she was honest
issues she wasn't in on her period like
she was very emotional it was
it was strange but like it was make
sense this was such a different
conversation it was reminding me of New
York House why yes when they won got
political when they went the whole
season was political so it's not the
first time we've reached politics on the
housewives it's it's always shocking
it's also like PTSD because like I
forgot that that happened like that
seems beause at eight months ago and now
it's like you're back in and it's like
oh my god PTSD the world win of Breck
have enough but I remember that day and
the whole world was talking about it so
it would have I'm gonna sleep been
impossible to go to a dinner and not
talk about it and you know what else is
so weird I was in Washington DC that
weekend during the hearings and I
couldn't get not to make it about me and
I couldn't get me embargo we're out of
hotel room and it was horrible and I was
like Margo let's move to another hotel
and we couldn't get one room anywhere
like not even a suite not even the worst
room and any hotel and I kept asking the
people on the phone I was calling all
the hotels I'm like why like what's
going on they're like we don't know how
we were said nobody knew I didn't know
that I was in DC during the hearings
until I got back because nobody in DC
was talking about it that is so I guess
like when you're so in the thick of it
like you don't care yeah it's the eye of
the storm yeah just an interesting
factoid that I found well interesting
and then the story about Lisa and his
mom oh my god that was so crazy I was so
crazy I don't never heard of that serial
killer but I guess he's like a famous
one yeah we're like he's there's a lot
of serious original cities away
yeah he's regional fame like I don't
think they made a neck looks documentary
about him so we wouldn't have heard of
him no that was so wild so wild what a
crazy story so many interesting factoids
and it's like we've known Lisa Rinna for
so many seasons now and we've been there
and and Louis and we've never heard that
story I love when people continue to
show us things like I just found out
that my sister was really talkative you
know anything like I love learning new
things about people even though I've
known them for a few years already
yeah it's just like it explains more of
who they are and it just makes you
appreciate like that they're both on
this planet and you know what when
Camille was like that she's getting
married for the second time like I kind
of had the feeling like she was married
more than that when she's in the second
time I go that's it yeah like she never
was married before Kelsey Kelsey or
after you know definitely not after you
look at a long time yeah I'm excited for
her to get married
me too I could go for a trip and a
wedding a wedding trip for sure yeah a
trapper shirt and the husband's go on
this trip and just Lisa V arrived on the
show because we reported this story that
all the women went to
wedding and Lisa didn't go which at the
time I thought meant that Lisa wasn't
invited right but I think it's just that
like this was when she stopped filming
and it's so weird that Camille insists
on taking the side of Lisa Vanderpump
every time even though she just turned
in and come to her wedding yeah so
clearly a lot more is gonna happen oh so
I just want to say like everyone the
conversation continues about Lisa
Vanderpump versus the ladies and
everyone is dying you know like Lisa
Vanderpump is doing what she does like
for TV blah blah blah but like when ik
when she's not like stirring [ __ ] up
like her life is so uninteresting her
doing her kitchen where it's like all
the other women like if you wanted to
show me like ten minutes of Kyle and her
family like no it's the same thing it's
Kyle boom of the grocery store is the
same type of scene but they would
consider as Lisa redoing her kitchen and
I couldn't have didn't even pick my head
up once for my computer while Lisa was
remodeling but I watch the entire scene
of Kyle and Portia go in the grocery
store don't think she doesn't want to go
to the grocery store there's so many
things about Kyle that are interesting
her sisters her dynamics the woman
Mauricio agency the house the robbery
exactly every like all of the women then
Rinna and her daughters people I mean
people just love her and Louis they
would watch her fart Harry Hamlin Erika
Jayne has the most historic agility of
it all the Mickey Minden of it all right
Teddy Mellencamp is John John's daughter
and she she keeps people accountable she
has really cute kids there's a lot going
on there to read don't get me started
oh my god no but Drita I could just look
at her I could watch her eat got her
hair and makeup done like forever
yeah she's interesting her house is
beautiful I love seeing different parts
of her house PK is a freak like there's
a lot to unpack there by the way on
watch what happens live and with Lisa
Rinna and Ciara who I'm not well like I
don't know enough about her but like she
was such a beautiful angel precious gem
of a woman the kindest person wouldn't
say cross word about no she would have a
large husband the night before literally
just sided the biggest time tracking in
football history and like she couldn't
have been more humble no no I am in love
with Ciara I remember there was a rumor
that she was a man that was so mean cuz
like she's literally the most beautiful
human being on the face of the earth
she's the longest shiniest legs like I
would die for and she's the most
perfectly media trained person in the
world because she wouldn't say a bad
thing about anything right and I think
that's just who she is you know she
seems like that's kid the Kardashian
loved her and he was I love her and I
said I'd stand her and her husband Andy
Brynna about the woman chasing to read
around the pool maybe there's a lawsuit
in there in debt right which we had all
seen on social media I think was even in
the toasters group but they refused to
discuss I didn't brought up on the show
when he asked her now why and obviously
all the women were there for it and
random was like well I wasn't gonna do
it because I brought up a lawsuit last
season thought it would be interesting
content and everyone turned like trouble
yeah so it's like and there are actually
a lot of lawsuits against the women like
I think half of the housewives are in
blah blah so yeah but no one won't bring
it up because it's like no you're damned
if you do and you're damned if you don't
and it's like we're getting to a place
where these housewives where it's like
yes we need people to start drama but if
you're starting drama for the sake of it
then you're a villain and it's just
getting into it's getting into a weird
place and you know what friendship I
really like Denise and Doreen love like
Denise was just like I invite her to my
house like she invited me on the trip
when she had just met me and like she
was so nice to me
look that's how you start a friendship
in a very normal way honestly I'm loving
Denise more and more every I meet you
and now I'm feeling like I feel like
she's a really good judge of character
seems like she likes Lisa Vanderpump but
she also is wary of her she said I don't
want to be on her bad side
right so now it's like whoever Denise
likes I like because I think Denise is
very pure of heart know me too and she
has no ulterior motives like she didn't
thirst onto the show like day Bravo
chased her they pianore four million
dollars she's just showing up to get her
check and leave
she has no horse in this race she's not
trying to take anyone down she doesn't
care if the show prospers if it doesn't
like Lisa Vanderpump feels like the show
is her responsibility to make
interesting Denise couldn't care less
she's just here to make friends
and if not the piece of [ __ ] out I'll
take my 4 million dollars and go back to
Malibu yes really cuz I don't believe it
I do I feel like if that were true and
she like I feel like the other women
would resent her like that the way that
like Rinna resents Lisa Vanderpump she
makes the most money on the show she
needs to bring the drama Denise is the
most famous person on the show and
Denise is bringing eyeballs of people
who might not watch housewives like
people who know Denise from back in the
day or just like yourselves yeah a
hundred percent and Bravo's like so
thirsty these days to have like actual
celebrities be on the show it's like
it's the show is growing and it's like
if you think about the numbers it's like
Lisa Vanderpump was confirmed to be one
of the first people to ever like two
seasons ago get a million dollars a
season so they're doing a Lisa
Vanderpump
million dollars what would they give an
actual celebrity who brings real
credibility to the show and brings the
Charlie Sheen of it all I don't know I
mean maybe it's just me and I don't
because you're not like a Jenny's
Richards Stan yeah but if you like and
you're like a little like different
generation than her but like back in the
day like she was everything to everyone
and like she went through this huge
problem
like I've never seen her name the
intensity's getting paid four million
dollars no Tinsley's not nearly as
famous as Denise no but she is Tinsley
needs to show the show brought Tinsley
back to life gave her money she was on
arrested in Palm Beach she had nothing
denise has a [ __ ] full life she has
kids she has a hot husband she just got
married she gets alimony and she's
[ __ ] rich okay she doesn't need so
I'm sure she they gave her a million
dollar offer she said what the hell do I
need a million dollars for then the game
four million she's like alright I'll
show up for four million dollars I don't
know I think I'm just curious I don't
think it's I wouldn't like to see their
CDs of the four million well I don't
think that's possible so in the meantime
where do you get confirmation from the
tabloids because I only once saw it like
written up in Daily Mail I know we
talked about it but beyond that like
Daily Mail gets it wrong sometimes yes
sometimes for sure but no one's ever
come out and confirm their salary but I
just believe it made a lot of sense when
I heard it oh it made a lot of sense
when I heard it and it doesn't make a
lot of sense to me now watching it well
they paid her before she showed up so
but I think the other women like would
be like okay you're getting paid four
million dollars and I'm getting paid it
happened but she doesn't crossed anyone
so no one has a reason not to like her I
don't know and I think they're just
happy that someone is bringing more
eyeballs to their show they were getting
paparazzi that [ __ ] someone's wedding
was there any paparazzi Camille
Grammer's wedding probably not there
might have been because we reported the
story yeah whatever anyways we have to
go let's start cooking for Passover I
think I'm gonna make I think I'm gonna
cook something I'm cooking myself in my
bed I'm just getting really nice I cook
that geez will you try them no put a
piece of chicken in there I like that
can you find them no I don't eat
vegetables they're delicious I believe
you I'll watch other people me like oh
I'm so happy for you you even try it
just like one chunk no for a sister and
then for anechoic I'm fine first for a
colleague yes sister no thank you guys
so much I hope everyone has an amazing
good Friday happy Easter to you and your
families Happy Passover
getting through the struggle of not
eating bread we are here with you and
we'll just be around all weekend you
know sharing our holiday traditions on
Instagram I'm moving in
which is so crazy and so it's a horrible
so I'll be packing all weekend what do I
pack for this move everything because
I'm not everything moving is no not
everything this on Saturday I will be
sparking joy in my apartment dead of
reading getting rid of things that don't
spark joy and on Sunday I'll be packing
but moving is like so treacherous and I
usually feel so bad for anyone who's
going through a move but I am so excited
to move that I'm actually like looking
forward doesn't attract energy 100% what
happened to me like I was so happy to
get out of my apartment I was growing
out of it literally day by day that the
fact that I was like sweating over a box
didn't like I will [ __ ] carrying my
couch if it means that I get to move
yeah I'm totally here for it so yeah
I'll be packing and yeah we'll see you
on Monday yes bye guys have a great
weekend happy holidays
you